hey everyone bandit here so vatividia
finally went live with his phenomenal
new lore video about elden ring and i oh
my god
was really happy to see that we agree on
most of the interpretations just a
little confidence boost for myself since
all of this lore is so muddled and
debatable which vati himself even said
in the video and vati is very much so
the guy when it comes to lore accuracy
so yeah it made me feel good anyway i
just wanted to point out that because
his video is live and so well put
together i'm not going to be taking the
time to explain the basics of the world
of eldon ring in every video i'm just
going to be creating these lore
breakdown videos with the understanding
that everyone's already seen vati
vidya's video as kind of a foundation to
build off of cool cool so yeah on to
this video's topic which is going to be
all about the newmans you know of them
you've heard their name even if you
weren't looking for it and here's a
spoiler alert for you they're extremely
important to the story and i'm gonna
break down all the information we can
see in-game and some interesting
theories surrounding their origin in a
way that anyone can understand also
spoiler alert in general for the video
you've been warned the newman race is
mentioned several times in the game but
first and foremost on the character
creation screen which is like the first
thing you see in the game pretty much
when you're choosing a race or preset or
whatever to base your character off of
one of the selections is newman the
selection says that the new men are the
supposed descendants of denizens of
another world long-lived but seldom born
this is the only race listed here that
is described as coming from another
world entirely which already kind of
gives them the sense of great importance
and if you combine the description of
the newman here with the description of
america's hammer you can corroborate the
information since the hammer says it was
created in the lands of the newman
outside the lands between aka another
world now that's great and fine and all
but you might be wondering why should we
care about some aliens from outer worlds
well as you might recall not only does
merica's hammer come from the lands of
the newman but so does america herself
the black knife assassins were all said
to be newman women with close ties to
america the newman's rune also states
that the new men come from outside the
lands between and are in fact of the
same stock as queen america and all of
this is pretty much saying without
saying that america equals newman now
something interesting that i was able to
find that might not mean much but is
still cool enough to mention is the fact
that the word newman is actually latin
for divine will or get this goddess and
fromsoft has actually used latin in
elden ring in other places as well such
as the lyrics to the song that the bat
women sing so it looks like the land of
the newmans means literally the land of
the goddesses and if we were to run with
this for a bit and open up a can of
speculation the word imperian that's
used in-game to describe those who are
fit for godhood means of the heavens or
divine in english and through some deep
dives into the elden rings subreddit i
was finally able to come across a
japanese translation of the word
imperian or rather the original
non-translated japanese similarly the
japanese word used there is xinjin which
according to the user tum na zelda means
god person now i don't know why they
didn't just use the same word but what
it sounds like to me is that being an
empirian and being a newman might be one
in the same and i mean think about it
all of the known empirians besides
america in the game right so ronnie
millenia and mikala are all each
directly related to america and are pure
of blood coming from a single god and
for the theory about ronnie coming from
a single god check out my previous
ronnie video and for the theory about
the mysterious gloamide queen who was
also an empyrean check out my melanoma
video anyway point is as a side note
that ultimately doesn't have much to do
with the actual content of the video
it's possible that being an empyrean
means being a newman or a direct
pure-blooded descendant of the newman
but that's neither here nor there so
let's get back on track we know the
newman are a mysterious possibly divine
race of people who hail from outside the
lands between but how did they get here
why are they here and where is their
land anyway is it possible to know any
of these things for sure yeah it is more
or less so let's start with that last
question where is the land of the
newmans for the answer to this one we're
gonna do a little cross referencing
starting with the black knife assassins
like i covered earlier they're all said
to be newman women that much we can tell
directly from their armor description
however if you progress a bit into raja
the sorcerer's quest line he will
eventually begin to talk to you about
the night of the black knives which is
the fateful night in which the rune of
death was stolen and used by the black
knife assassins to kill the soul of
godwin and the body of ronnie rajeir
being a straight up lbpd detective tries
to figure out who done it as a part of
his research he was able to figure out
that the assassins who carried out the
deed were quote scions of the eternal
city a group entirely of women arrayed
an armor of silver under cloaks which
fooled the eye this matches up perfectly
with what we know to be true about the
black knife assassins being both women
and arrayed in silver caped armor so we
have no reason to not believe what rajer
is saying but something he said should
stand out to you he didn't call them
newman he called them scions of the
eternal city a scion by the way in terms
of humanity is a descendant of a royal
or important family which lines up with
what we know the newman to be
descendants of denizens of another world
so clearly he is talking about the
newman thing is he claims that the
newman are from the eternal city as you
probably remember from playing the game
there are three eternal cities called
nochron noxtella and one that's unnamed
and they're each located far beneath the
ground but is that far enough down to be
considered outside the lands between a
different world i mean it's definitely a
long way down that's for sure it's
debatable but there is some soft proof
that it is to be considered outside the
lens between if we read the map
description for either the einzel or co
for rivers it states that the great
rivers flow beneath the lands between
which given their depth and great nature
could be interpreted as being outside
the lands between there's also the fact
that the entire lake of rot is down here
which is said to literally house the
essence of an outer god also known as
the scarlet rot and the fact that the
mogwin palace is down here that's
supposed to be the capital of moog's
dynasty in service to another outer god
called the formless mother combine the
presence of these other outer gods that
are not the greater will the
descriptions of the great rivers the
fact that multiple newman's runes can be
found down here and to the fact that the
black knife assassins are said to be
newmans who come from both the eternal
city and another world and you're left
with the probability that the lands
underneath the lands between are in fact
considered another world i mean there
are even actual stars hanging in the sky
down here so clearly there's something
weird going on anyway if the newman and
therefore america herself came from the
lands underneath the lands between that
opens up a whole can of worms because
you know what the eternal cities were
known and destroyed for defiance of the
greater will the civilizations that
lived down there who came from the
surface and predated the age of the
earth tree by the way were responsible
for creating the finger slayer blade
which ronnie eventually tasks you with
retrieving in order to slay her own two
fingers the defiance of the eternal
cities is why the tyrannical greater
will devastated them and why they are
now filled with monsters and are only a
shadow of their former glory but if
america being a newman came from the
people who used to live in the eternal
cities then this just gives a much
better understanding as to why she
double-crossed the greater will just to
remind everyone remember that merica
shattered the elden ring an act which
the greater will called a trespass
because that's kind of their entire
connection to the lands between locking
her up within the urge tree as
punishment but america predicted that
they'd do this to her and had already
set in motion a plan for the greater
will to out of desperation offer grace
once again to her first husband godfrey
and his tarnished who would then
eventually venture to her imprisoned
body and rid it of the control of the
elden beast now nobody debates whether
or not she betrayed the greater will but
what people do debate is why she did it
until now everyone just kind of assumed
that america got cold feet about this
whole vessel of the greater will thing
and decided to shatter the elden ring
out of anger at the greater will and the
death of her firstborn but if she were
to have come from the eternal cities
then all of a sudden it makes sense it
could be that merica did all of this
became queen and vessel for the elden
ring in the first place in order to do
what her fellow newman previously failed
to to take down the greater will she
rose to power and surrendered herself to
the greater will and accepted the elden
ring and eldon beast into herself in
order to destroy it which is what
happens no matter what at the end of the
game it's a nice bit of lore diving but
right about now you're probably thinking
to yourself what about the other newman
women the black knife assassins since we
know that they are closely related to
queen america and are of the same stock
doesn't that then imply that merica and
the black knife assassins are on the
same side and that she probably
orchestrated their plot but if she did
set the knight of the black knives in
motion then why would she have them kill
her son godwin the firstborn and
favorite of america the one whose death
was kind of a big deal that is a great
question and of course not one that can
be answered without a bit more
theorizing but hey why stop now see like
vati said in his video there are several
reasons to believe that america actually
orchestrated the knight of the black
knives one of the biggest reasons is of
course that she is a newman just like
the black knife assassins which is
already a super huge connection but
another reason is that her shadow
malaketh was said to have been betrayed
by her now i always thought this was
weird like how was america supposed to
have betrayed malekith when all she
really had him do was defeat the glomide
queen and her can apostles then keep a
watch over the rune of death was that
supposed to be her betrayal just asking
him to do that i'm not really seeing
much betrayal here except for i guess
the fact that malekith becomes addicted
to eating death root but that doesn't
make a lot of sense because he wasn't
like that until he embedded the rune of
death within his own body which didn't
happen until after it was stolen from
him on the night of the black knives
ah-ha light bulb see while i was
puzzling over this notion of america's
betrayal lo and behold a savior a timely
prometheus of lore descended upon my
twitter dms sharing their take on this
very subject with me who they called
their favorite lore person on youtube i
know i'm not going to cry anyway roxaff
pointed out that if you kill malaketh as
garak the beast clergyman he will ask
marika why she would gull him why she
would shatter before passing away and
not finishing his sentence don't you
hate when people die before finishing
their sentences so annoying the word
goal by the way means to deceive so
again we have proof that malekith was
deceived or betrayed by america but how
well like roxaff points out what if the
betrayal was the theft of the rune of
death see in my previous videos i've
stated over and over that i believe
marika was the one who removed the rune
of death aka destined death from the
elden ring spawning the golden order
like any it tells us and this is still
true i think but it was most likely not
something america did of her own
volition roxaff brought up the fact that
this logically has to be the case
because if america removed destin death
against the greater will's will then why
should they not permit its return and he
tells us straight up that the fingers in
greater will itself would not allow its
return meaning that the greater will
most likely commanded america to remove
death from the elden ring in order to
ensure that the reign via the elden
beast inside america was eternal in
order to allow the greater will to rule
over the lands between forever and this
is what created the golden order that we
know of today back to malakith though if
merika had him take the rune of death
but then orchestrated its theft for the
black knives which then led to malekith
destroying his own mind over embedding
the rune of death inside his very body
then that could be considered deceit or
betrayal either that or she betrayed him
by shattering the elden ring and turning
against the golden order but it just
feels strange to single out malekith as
the only person she betrayed in that
case either way though it does seem very
likely that america masterminded the
stealing of the rune of death in order
to combine it with her other initiative
which would be the god-slaying weapon
that she was having huge create and
therefore combine them to forge a weapon
imbued with the power of the rune of
death capable of killing an outer god
however this is where ronnie comes into
play remember that ronnie claims to have
stolen a fragment of the rune of death
in order to create the black knives
through fearsome right so what if this
means that ronnie hijacked america's
plans and stole a fragment of the rune
of death and used it for her own rise to
power now i go into much more detail
regarding ronnie's full story in the
ronnie explain video so i won't explain
everything again here but remember that
ronnie is an emperian a pure blood
descendant of ratigan aka america the
newman and in my opinion that probably
means that ronnie herself was also a
newman she did show some strange
connections and knowledge of the eternal
cities and their hubris she knew of the
finger slayer blade's existence after
all and her associate eg wears a mirror
helm which is supposed to ward off
interference from the greater will and
is extremely similar to the nox mirror
helm which is also supposed to ward off
the greater will's interference and is
part of the nox set and you know who the
knox people are they are the very people
who long ago pissed off the greater will
and were banished too you guessed it the
eternal cities but you might be
wondering doesn't this mean that the
knox are the citizens of the eternal
cities and not the newman listen don't
be put off that some races of people
have multiple names like the nox
potentially being the newman or an older
version of them in the first place since
the new men are so rare and only pop up
every now and then it could be that they
are simply a specific bloodline or
family within the knox people and since
this game loves multiple names for the
same things like the erd tree probably
being the great tree or the dust guide
queen probably being the glomite queen
or rena being ronnie or margat being
morgut it is entirely possible that both
the knox and the new men could both come
from the lands underneath and are
therefore both connected to one another
geographically and in their defiance of
the greater will anyway it could be that
ronnie simply convinced the black knife
assassins her fellow newman to murder
her own body and godwin's soul in order
to aid in the rise of ronnie's age of
the stars perhaps the newman women began
to lose faith in queen america after so
many years of her apparent devotion and
complete service to the greater will
ronnie on the other hand promised
complete destruction of the greater will
and the golden order which is what the
knox and newman have wanted all along
and this may have been enough to
convince the black knife assassins to
follow through with her plans even if it
meant killing the innocent godwin i
think it's also interesting that
godwin's body turned up afterwards in
the unnamed eternal city which is where
the newman women might have called home
however i also think that the fact that
the black knife assassins showed up to
kill ronnie's associates eg and blythe
after her questline was done is very
important they must have lost faith in
ronnie and swung back to serving america
or the greater will at this point it's
not clear i'll admit this part has me
stumped because there are no pieces that
explain this but anyway the fact that
ronnie and godwin both died led to
america's legitimate dismay and forced
her hand into shattering the elden rings
since she no longer had a handle on the
rune of death which of course led to the
shattering war which led to the greater
will reviving the tarnish to quell the
nonsense and restore the elden ring and
the rest is playable history but the
newman no matter what you may believe
about the lore of the elden ring are
undoubtedly right in the middle of it
all and that my friends is my theory
about the women of newman and their
significance in the story as a whole but
what did you guys think are the newman
women from the eternal cities below and
did they really betray america by
following ronnie's orders to assassinate
godwin or is this all just a bunch of
baseless speculation and the women of
newman really are just aliens from
another planet let me know in the
comments below also thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed it or at
least my efforts into making it please
consider leaving a like on the video as
these videos take lots of time and brain
power to put together and subscribe if
you haven't already for many more lore
videos to come huge thanks as always to
my bandit crew of which i have the
fabulous xander bee to welcome into the
fold that's all i've got for this one so
as always i hope you have a wonderful
rest of your day this is bandit looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out peace
[Music]
you